[Music]
there's no place like home and that's
why we're celebrating as many hometowns
as we can all across the country all
season long
next up is portland oregon where
culinary professional judy ann wu calls
home i hear she makes it her mission to
know all the best restaurants and chefs
in town now that's a woman after my own
heart let's watch
hey drew it is caramack host of k2's
afternoon live your sibling show in
portland oregon and i know you are
celebrating hometown spirit well no one
has more hometown spirit than our very
own julianne moon judy and share with
people what portland's so awesome
portland is my hometown and love it so
much there are so many amazing places to
eat and drink plus scenic beauty and the
most passionate and creative people you
will ever meet and you're gonna show it
off for everyone so we're gonna send you
off have so much fun
welcome to omsi omg stands for the
oregon museum of science and industry
it's got something for everybody you
learn about the earth the universe and
everything in between
we have here giant australian walking
sticks this is one corner of the museum
where they have actual live creatures
that you can interact with such as these
say hello to drew
i'm here at toki restaurant in the heart
of downtown portland and behind me is
chef owner peter cho
he's doing his take on the most
delicious crave-worthy korean-american
classics this is like you know portable
food
so good yes
portland is also known as the rose city
and what better place to wrap up our
tour than the international rose test
gardens here on the grounds we have 10
000 different bushes representing over
610 varieties of roses in every single
color imaginable it's the ultimate place
to find your zen well drew that was just
a quick peek at portland the city we
love so much we can't wait for you to
come visit see you soon
thanks judy ann i remember going to
naomi pomeroy's restaurant beast and we
hung out all night long one of the great
nights of my life we're definitely
hanging out the next time i'm in
portland see you soon
[Music]
you